[Applause]
this is such a vast spiderweb of
contacts this data that we'll be
transferring between phones will now be
encrypted what more do we know about how
this is actually going to work the
clamor to improved contact tracing has
seen nations like Israel Singapore South
Korea and of course China using a
combination of location data video
camera footage and credit card
information to track and contain kovat
19 in their countries we're prepared and
we're doing a great job with it it will
go away just stay calm
the US has lagged behind but Google and
Apple are feverishly building a contact
tracing platform scheduled for release
in mid-may it will enable the use of
Bluetooth technology to help governments
and health agencies reduce the spread of
the virus by tracing people who have
come into close contact with Koba 19 but
how exactly this information will be
used in the future and with whom is an
open question we're kind of at this
fascinating moment right where we don't
know exactly what the response is gonna
look like
we know that robust contact tracing
that's gonna be a huge part of reopening
the economy and we know that we have to
balance that with privacy concerns
somehow but we don't know exactly what
the balance is going to look like and I
leave it up to the epidemiologist to say
whether you need to be as repressive as
China or if there are ways to protect
privacy we might not have a ton of time
to debate it and that's kind of the
problem
there are currently few legal
protections from data misuse or abuse
and while some states do have some laws
in place progress on this front has been
halted there was some privacy momentum
in Congress before the pandemic hit and
that's been destroyed for obvious
reasons California passed a privacy law
a couple of years ago and there's been a
lot of work to try to improve it as it
goes into effect this year a bunch of
other states had been considering
privacy legislation as well like
Washington State in New York and then
kovat comes and
a lot of the state legislatures have
just pretty much shut down now before
you envision a black mirror episode for
your personal future you should know the
as of now involvement will be voluntary
the data it collects is to be anonymized
and there will be no central server
where the data is stored so governments
or corporations can't directly grab all
this private data for its own purposes
but that could easily change there's
nothing really to stop them from having
a centralized database it's only kind of
the restraint of our expectations if our
expectations were to become overturned
and again shift tremendously over to
safety it could become a lot more
Orwellian a lot quicker
there's many scenarios that could be
quite troubling your information could
be given to insurance companies and it
could be used as a pre-existing
condition that prevents you from getting
insurance or as a reason to charge you
much higher prices the information could
be sold to data brokers who could then
package it to anyone that they want the
information could end up with your
employer who could use it to make
decisions about whether to promote you
because of your health now that may
sound a little paranoid but we have good
reason to be suspicious these are
entities that already collect enormous
amounts of our data in a commercial
context whose mishandling of data has
come under fire in the past exhibit a
Cambridge analytic at Cambridge
analytical Cambridge analytical we just
strayed it away like everything there is
to know about ourselves you know for
farmville and I think that people
starting to realize that wasn't a good
trade in 2016 the big data company
Cambridge analytic I took the personal
data of millions of Americans from
Facebook they packaged it and sold it so
the political groups could then target
parts of the population with narrow
casted messages you know people were
sharing information with friends and
they weren't necessarily expecting that
data to be shared by a company like
Cambridge analytic a that was making use
of it to build political profiles and
serve specific advertisements or
propaganda gamer channel Erica really
captures the dilemma of privacy which is
how data collected for one reason with
certain expectations is used for another
reason we have been giving away all of
our most private information to
companies that have been sold it on and
created what is now a multi trillion
dollar a year industry this was business
as usual as far as Facebook developers
went this scandal resulted in the
Federal Trade Commission's finding of
Facebook for five billion dollars as
well as a general push for broader
privacy laws we didn't take a broad
enough view of our responsibilities and
that was a big mistake and it was my
mistake and I'm sorry which are seen is
a greater bipartisan concern about the
power of these data op Elise and how do
we rein them in so how do we know this
isn't gonna happen this time the answer
comes back to those privacy protection
laws that have been put on hold because
of the pandemic there had been a
National privacy law enacted before the
pandemic hit us we probably would have
been in a better position to respond to
it with data but even if there was a
National privacy law in place contact
tracing is actually pointless if we
don't have widespread testing to go
along with it which we don't so what is
this about is this a smokescreen for
collecting a lot of data is the data
truly gonna stay in on eyes or
aggregated the pandemic is showing why a
general privacy law is so important
because there's so much confusion around
data collection concern that there will
be overreach and lack of rules about how
the information could be used for other
purposes laws are going to be needed to
stem a lot of this corporate
I think you're only going to see those
efforts continue you know short term I
think they may be delayed because of
Ovid but I think the the fundamental
concerns around overly broad corporate
collection aren't going away they don't
see some centralized bureaucracy that
will then be shared with the police and
the IRS and your future employer and
your future insurer
at least not right now but it is worth
noting that some of those things aren't
forbidden
[Music]